um
six
is
[ __ ]
oh
okay
okay
so
sir
foreign
this
check
foreign
so
yes
oh
so
quartz
someone's waiting to go
oh
hey steve
oh
california
yeah uh would you tell me if my camera
is working yep
you're there
is
huh
just yeah to double check
uh
okay
all right
bye
thank
so
so
so
so
done so far but anderson remember that
just 24 hours ago that in this room the
president was going after caballeros
saying that she was disrespectful
calling her a nasty person he said
disrespectful to judge
joseph that is he was referencing and
today the tables returned and it was her
turn to go after him and to criticize
him
and she did that by going after their
response to the pandemic smoking the
nation
saying that he failed to listen to the
signs from the start
from the experts about this he failed to
take the virus seriously
from the beginning something that's seen
in reporting in other reporting shows
extensively we should note and she
basically accused the president of being
the reason there is such a high number
of american deaths from food in 19 right
now and saying it was a lack
of a good response from not only donald
trump but also vice president mike pence
she also talked about the economy what
it looks like before you heard that
when she said something and this is
likely a line that could sting for the
president when she said that
he basically inherited this great
economy from president obama
and vice president joe biden and she
said like everything else
that he inherited he ran straight into
the ground that is the quote that she
used there so
those are likely the moments that the
president was watching closely as he was
watching that speech taking it in and
there is certainly a good chance we
could hear the president respond
to those accusations to those insults
from kamala here
from homelanders when he comes out here
here
what
was it
two minutes
i know right here
so
foreign
um
didn't go welcome
there was only one it sounded like two
yes
hey
thank you very much
appreciate you being here
and good evening as we continue to
confront the
china virus we're rebuilding america's
economy like
nobody thought possible actually we're
doing incredibly well stock markets up
almost 300 points again today
while our economy is performing
significantly better than
europe which people have to understand
very
strongly it's performing better than any
market anywhere in the world actually
at the same time europe has experienced
a 40 percent
higher excess mortality than the
united states and i will say that uh
that's
a significant number we're working with
europe on their difficulties and we are
going to help them all the way we're
doing very well as you know the vaccines
and the
therapeutics but think of that we have
the strongest economy
performing economy in the world we're up
uh
i think it's nine trillion dollars since
march 9 trillion dollars in value
that's a that's a number that nobody's
ever heard of before
we're also uh getting close to about a
50
number since march which is incredible
so it's nine trillion dollars it's
almost 50 in fact i think it went above
50
today with the 300 point increase
and it's uh so we're doing much better
than europe significantly
and at the same time europe has
experienced a 40 percent
higher excess mortality than the united
states
i just want to mention because another
number of judges were
approved recently will be probably over
300 judges federal judges including
court of appeals judges approved by the
end of my first term
and other than the when they added new
judges
into somebody's term which happened to
seldom
but we have more than any uh there's a
record nobody's
ever seen anything like this in one term
so we're going to have over
300 federal judges and that's court of
appeals
judges and that's just in the first term
which
probably will finish out over 300 which
is
pretty amazing the stock market's
rebound signals a v-shaped recovery
stronger than our
competitors anywhere in the world
stronger if you look
you'll see exactly what we have
we uh we lead the world japan is second
but in terms of uh dollar value it's not
even close
so there it is a lot of great
competitors europe united kingdom japan
china hong kong
the united states is leading the world
very substantially
the second slide you'll see the virus
induced economic contraction
in the united states has been far
less severe than it was with our peers
and peer nations
and you see that right there there's the
united states
and that's despite the fact that we've
done more testing than any other nation
in the world
that we've done more by far ventilators
we're building
thousands and thousands of ventilators a
month and we're
distributing them all over the world
we're helping other countries
uh but despite all of these factors
the shallowest contraction which is a
big deal
i'm sure you'd love to put them in your
various
media outlets i know you want to get
that out if you want to leave the room
early and do that that would be fine the
rapid recovery
but it would be nice to report it the
rapid recovery of homebuilders
sentiment points to massive new
construction and we are
doing massive amounts of construction of
new homes and that's because people have
tremendous confidence this is where we
went
and the housing market has quickly
rebounded we were at a record and now
we're going to be at a record again very
shortly
those numbers are incredible that's
where we are
we had to turn off the economy and now
we're turning it back on and that's
beyond division this is going to be uh
very strong
it's called the strong v automobile
demand has increased
65 over the last three months
65 automobile demand
and we're anticipating that that's going
to go up even further but that's more
than any
anybody else the manufacturing sector
remember manufacturing is dead according
to the past
administration of obama and by
manufacturing is dead you'd need a magic
wand well you don't need a magic wand
you need
competence and capability the
manufacturing set
sector is booming and the production
index is at the highest reading since
october of 18 which is uh
was a an extraordinary period of time
and there we are that's pretty good
these are numbers that nobody has seen
until just recently and now that he's
just coming out
these are numbers that are leading
i guess stock market people they're very
smart people
i know many of them and they're seeing
things that they don't even believe so
the manufacturing sector is booming
and the production index is at its
highest reading in a long long time
the economy generated over nine million
jobs
in the last three years a record by far
and 12 million more jobs than experts
predicted
so there you are you look at that
and that's a record and it's a record
for the quarter
we had over 9 million substantially more
than 9 million jobs
so those are incredible numbers about
our economy and how it's coming back
it's coming back very strongly it's
coming back
at a level that's far greater than
anybody anticipated
and we're very proud of that and i give
a lot of credit to all of our people
steve and larry
uh we'll be uh talking about it if you
have any questions on it i
shouldn't have any questions uh i didn't
i didn't print those charts
who did the economy journal i think
let's see i don't know we'll find that
out for you but
it wasn't us we took those we took those
numbers from
somebody where did you get those numbers
larry they're from where
bls jobs reporting pls jobs report
through july okay everybody has that
everybody needs the democrats have
abandoned the american
people over the simple subject of
politics
chuck schumer and nancy pelosi are
holding the american people hostage over
money for their
radical left-wing agenda that the
country doesn't want and won't accept
for example they've asked for a
ridiculous 3.5
billion dollars that's billion 3.5
billion dollars
for universal mail-in voting a system
riddled by fraud and corruption you just
look at what happened with the carolyn
maloney race they should do that race
over by the way
i think her opponent is right when he is
having fits
about that race when you look at the
ballot
the ballots that are missing and the
ballot frauds nobody knows what's going
on with that race and yet they declared
her
a winner so her opponent i don't know
what's happened over the last 24 hours
but her
opponent is rightfully going a little
bit crazy
and then you look at what happened in
virginia where they have 500 000
applications sent out at random to
people
that have no idea what happened and they
admitted they made a mistake and
many were sent to dead people men were
sent to
number were sent i guess two that at
least two three four
were sent to dogs one was sent to a cat
they're sent all over the place that was
in virginia and paterson new jersey
they had a massive amount of voter fraud
and it's been a disaster paterson new
jersey have been total disaster that's
universal
mail-in voting so they want 3.5 billion
dollars for universal mail-in voting for
the country where you have
hundreds of millions of voters they
can't do a little race with 20
000 people now they want to take it
countrywide mail-in voting it's going to
be the greatest
fraud in the history of elections when
you always
talk about russia russia russia china
yeah iran on voting
your biggest problem is going to be with
the democrats not with
china russia and iran your biggest
problem is going to be with the
democrats
but now the democrats they want 3.5
billion dollars think of it
but now that they're unwilling to
approve a bill that gives all of
that money of course we would never
approve an amount like that
and they also won 25 billion dollars
additional for the post office steve
25 billion for the post office so the
post office can handle this vast
amount of ballots that are being sent at
random all over the place
they have no idea where they're going so
they want 25 billion and they want
think of this they want 3.5 billion
would you say that's enough to cover it
i think we could do it for less
right i think we could do it for less
but they won 25 billion for the post
office because of
this and remember the new man who's a
great
person a great businessman just got
there
a little while ago the post office has
been
run poorly for many many decades
great people in the post office
incredible people but they've had very
bad leadership for many years so
we'll get it straightened out but they
turn down
this bill because they want radical left
agenda items that nobody in their right
mind would approve
so they want 25 billion for the post
office they went 2.5
with 3.5 billion dollars for universal
mailing 3.5 billion
and the bill's not going to happen
because they don't even want to talk
about it
because we can't give them the kind of
ridiculous things that they want that
have nothing to do with the
china virus has nothing at all to do
with china virus much of what they're
asking for
so therefore they don't have the money
to do the universal
mail-in voting so therefore they can't
do it i guess
right are they going to do it even
though they don't have the money they're
asking for the 3.5 billion
they're asking for 25 billion for the
post office so they can
do this i guess in other things at 25 i
would hope it would be a lot of other
things too
but therefore they don't have it
they don't have the money to do the
universal mail-in
votes it'll be the greatest rigged
election in history it'll be
the greatest fraud ever perpetrated
other than perhaps what they did to my
campaign where they spied on my campaign
president obama biden and everybody else
and they got caught let's see what
happens this will be one of the greatest
frauds in history
so they're admitting that they want 3.5
billion
and they're not going to do
a deal that's good for the american
people therefore they're not going to
get the 3.5 billion therefore
they can't do the universal
mail-in vote it's very simple how are
they going to do it if they don't have
the money to do it
the democrats are also holding up money
for schools and
hospitals and small businesses and state
and local governments
they tried to stop americans from
getting unemployment insurance and
protection from evictions which is why i
took this decisive action
and i did executive orders which are now
in full force in effect
and they're going forward i signed a
directive to provide a total of four
hundred dollars
of additional support for americans who
are unemployed
due to the china virus that's four
hundred dollars more than the democrats
have provided
remember that that's four hundred
dollars more than the democrats have
provided
nancy and chuck haven't provided
anything
and remember this president obama
when we had a problem
a pretty big problem a very big problem
you know what he gave 25 dollars he gave
25 bucks
so now they say well we want to give 500
or we want to give 600 they don't want
to give they don't give anything they're
not
doing anything but president obama and
biden
sleepy joe gave 25 25
and they'll complain oh we want to give
more well we're giving 400
dollars and that's now in the works and
that'll be getting out to the people
soon steve okay
remember that 25 is what they gave the
last time
25 i want to make it unmistakably clear
that i'm protecting people from
evictions
they didn't want to do that the
democrats didn't want to do
a protection from evictions people
getting evicted because of the
coronavirus or the china virus whatever
you want to call it with 20 now we're up
to 21 different names
all we know is it came out of china and
it shouldn't have they should have
stopped it
under my executive order hud hhs and cdc
have been directed to ensure renters and
homeowners that they can stay
safely in their homes they're not going
to be evicted they are not going to be
evicted
and those letters have already been sent
out steve so
you'll make sure that i'm providing a
payroll tax holiday to all americans
earning less than 100 000 per year
meaning bigger paychecks for
working families through the end of
2020.
that's a tremendous amount of money
that's being
supplied and given to families
tremendous the democrats didn't want to
do a payroll tax
they thought it was too much money i
guess
or would make businesses too successful
they don't want to see success
they certainly don't want to see it
before the election they certainly don't
want to see
the kind of graphs and charts that you
saw up there they don't because they say
they can't win
with that kind of success they can't win
they have to get used to it
remember we've already gotten three
trillion dollars in stimulus so
um they should have probably negotiated
a little bit differently
maybe they should have asked for all of
this before
we got most of the money and we gave it
out a lot of it to the people
when we win the election when i win the
election i'm going to completely and
totally forgive all deferred payroll
taxes
without in any way shape or form hurting
social security that money is going to
come from the general fund
we're not going to touch social security
i said from day one
that we're going to protect social
security
and we're going to
protect our people and social security
is one of the
things that will be protected
pre-existing conditions will be
protected medicare will be protected
but social security will be totally
protected under me under them it will
not be protected because we will have a
stock market crash the likes of which
you've never seen
your taxes will be doubled and tripled
and your regulations will go through the
roof which is what was causing the
problems with the country in the first
place student loans
i signed the director providing relief
to student borrowers
not their fault that they can't go to
college
i will be deferring payments on student
loans at zero interest
until further notice so we're going to
take care of our students
a lot of great students out there and
they they got hit like everybody else
so i will be deferring payments on
student loans at zero interest until
further notice
and then the payroll tax will be
terminating the payroll tax
after i hopefully get elected we'll be
terminating the payroll tax so that will
mean
anywhere from five thousand to even more
per family
and also great for businesses and great
for jobs
a lot of people will be very happy to
hear that a lot of the great certainly
conservative
economists would be great to have they
think that's the greatest thing we can
do that's better than the payments
that's better than anything else
but it's a lot of money and it's uh it's
going right directly to the people
and it goes there very easily but it
also creates stronger
companies to employ the people so we
will be
on the assumption i win we are going to
be
terminating the payroll tax after the
beginning of the new year
today i met with parents students
teachers and health experts to discuss
the vital importance
safety and safely reopening america's
schools this evening i'll outline the
common sense recommendations that should
guide schools as
they reopen with precautions we want to
be very
very safe and very careful so
precautions in place
our strategy to safely reopen schools
mirrors our
approach nationwide as we race toward
the competition
and the completion we're competing with
others but i'm not completing
competing with anyone we just want to
have a vaccine we have we're dealing
with other countries
and we want them to do well we're giving
them whatever information they need
we're all working towards something that
will
happen will happen before the end of the
year maybe substantially before but
before
the end of the year and therapeutics
will happen likewise
uh even sooner
but we're looking for that responsible
path forward to shelter those at highest
risk while
allowing those at lower risk to resume
work and school
and play football go play football
i spoke to some of the great football
players college players
trevor and a lot of great
players called coach coach called
coach a lot of fantastic people
i got to speak to athletes leaders
they want to play football let them play
let them play and they'll
they feel safer in the field and they do
uh walking around and
doing nothing so hopefully that will
happen
and hopefully when they play football
they will proudly stand for the national
anthem and they will
proudly stand and and respect the
american flag
or at least i'm not watching i can't
speak for others but based on
what i see now and based on what i'm
looking at with respect to the nba at
this point a lot of people agree with me
so we want people we would like to
request people you stand proudly for
the flag and for the national anthem
in the months since the virus arrived
we've learned
a great deal while this is a dangerous
and highly infectious disease
it primarily affects the oldest segment
of our population
or those with chronic health issues the
united states has the largest nursing
home
and assisted living home population
in the western world by far nearly half
of all of the deaths from the china
virus in the united states have occurred
in nursing homes and
long-term care facilities the median age
of those who succumb to the virus is 78
years old
these findings underscore that all
americans must continue to apply extreme
vigilance in protecting our elderly
population and those with
chronic conditions outcomes are very
different for younger americans without
serious health issues tremendously
different
they can often expect mild or moderate
symptoms or
even no symptoms whatsoever
they have very strong immune systems
we've learned even more so than we ever
thought in a typical year approximately
five times
as many americans under the age of 65
die from heart disease
as have so far been lost to the
coronavirus
from the same age group that's an
interesting statistic
plus blessedly children appear
to face the lowest risk of all
it's 99.995 of all fatilities
are adults think of that 99.95
that is extremely close to a hundred
percent
of all fatalities are
adults children often have only mild
symptoms
and medical complications are incredibly
rare
very very very rare those that do face
complications often have underlying
medical conditions
in each of the last five years the flu
resulted in more deaths
of those under 18 in the united states
than
have been lost thus far to coronavirus
by far
the flu the flu does kill young people
given these considerations we believe
many school districts can now reopen
safely provided they
implement mitigation measures and health
protocols to protect families
protect teachers and protect students
all
families should be empowered to make the
decision
that is right for their own
circumstances
this is especially important if a child
has underlying health conditions or
lives with a parent or grandparent
who is at a high risk and one of the
things we'd like to do
is when we make payment to schools
because we spend a lot of money on
schools we'd like to make the payment
directly to the
student or to the child
and that would mean to the parents
essentially but to the child we want to
follow the child
so that if the school is closed the
family can go to another school
maybe in another area but they can do it
and would like to make that payment
rather than paying a school that's
closed would rather pay
directly we're following the child where
the child goes and we want to pay the
family paid the child
and then the family can take care of the
cost
and we're trying to get that approved
too but the democrats don't like doing
anything unless it means
doing for the union which controls
nancy and controls chuck 100
and i have nothing wrong with the union
i have great respect more than
very few people do i respect more than a
great teacher
it's a tremendous talent they're really
under appreciated these are phenomenal
people with
tremendous talent that the great ones
are among the most important people we
have
this country but
and they'll be great at other they'll be
greater charter schools
they'll be great at uh when we talk
about school choice which we'd like to
see
so that parents can take their children
to
the school of their church that's
something we want we think it's very
important especially in the
minority communities they want it so
badly
african-american hispanic american
asian-american they want it so badly
but the the two people i mentioned
nancy and chuck they're totally
controlled by the heads of the union
i think the teachers like us a lot we're
taking care of our teachers we want to
take care of our teachers
but we cannot indefinitely stop 50
million american children from
going to school and harming their mental
physical emotional and academic
development and inflicting
long-term lasting damage i heard a
gentleman today a great
person some of you are at that meeting
from harvard say that every year is ten
thousand dollars it's
uh people they lose a tremendous amount
of money in the future
mentioned ten thousand dollars
and i think he was talking about on a
yearly basis they lose a lot by
every year of education that they lost
every year they gained
they gained ten thousand dollars and
when you have
students sitting at home playing with a
computer it's not the same
that's one thing we've learned for sure
it's not the same can never be the same
as being in a classroom so we want to
get our students in the classroom
the american academy of pediatrics
has released guidance recommendation
that schools reopened they said reopen
it said quote
lengthy time away from school and
associated
interruption of supportive services
often results
in social isolation making it difficult
for schools to identify and address
important learning deficits the doctors
also warned about the risk of increased
abuse
substance use depression
and suicide suicide
the national education association
recently stated despite
the momentous efforts of educators
during the pandemic
online learning has never been an
effective replacement for
in-person learning and support so when
you sit at home in a basement looking at
a computer your brain starts to wither
away
we have a lot of good experience
at that just by taking a look at what's
happening in politics
studies estimate that school closures
last
spring caused the average student to
fall 50 percent behind in math and
roughly
35 in reading compared to a
typical year think of that because the
average student to full 50
behind in math and 35 in reading
compared to being at the school being
with your teachers being in a classroom
we've learned that we've learned that
learning from a laptop
is not great and frankly we've also
learned that
telehealth a little unrelated but
it's up 35 000 and it's been
incredible 35 000 percent
we'll check that number ladder but
that's an incredible but it is people
staying home and the telehealth that has
been a tremendous success
we've learned those two things during
this period of time with the
with the plague with the plague coming
in and those are two things we know
school
closures harm low income students the
most
because they have less access to high
quality remote learning
they don't have computers and less
resources for
academic support all schools should be
making plans to resume in-person
classes as soon as possible
to support the reopening of america's
schools we provided 13 billion dollars
in
elementary and secondary schools
toward the cares act and karzak funding
we're giving cares act funding the vast
majority of which remain available
for states to use so a tremendous amount
of money
13 billion dollars that's the cares act
funding and we're
giving a large portion of that for
states to use today i'm pleased to
announce that we will provide
up to 125 million
reusable masks to various
school districts all around the country
my administration also
stands ready to deploy cdc teams
to support schools that are opening
and schools that need help in safety
and in order to safely reopen
finally today my administration is
highlighting general recommendations for
all schools and guidance to protect
high-risk
teachers and students we're working very
very closely with
many of the schools and school districts
throughout the country
they include the following to ensure all
students
teachers and staff understand the
symptoms
of the china virus require all students
teachers and staff to
self-assess their health every morning
before coming to school
encourage frequent hand washing or hand
sanitizing during the school day
beginning upon entrance to school and
ensuring that hand washing facilities
are widely available throughout the
school and for the most part schools
have been very good at that
minimize large indoor gatherings
hold large gatherings outdoors whenever
possible
maintain high standards of hygiene and
ventilation within the classrooms
including keeping windows and doors open
whenever possible
and running fans and air conditioning
units
whenever possible require students
teachers and staff
to socially distance around
high-risk individuals and socially
distance whenever possible
in any event encourage the use of masks
when
social distancing is not possible
post instructions regarding hygiene and
social distancing all over the school
and all around the school
we encourage schools to adopt these
measures
we've been working with so many of them
and to the best of my knowledge
virtually every one of them agrees to do
that
while we're also providing high-risk
teachers and students options to engage
in
distance teaching or learning
we're working on that also college
age students also continue to be one of
the lowest risk
demographics more than 99.8 percent of
the deaths
from this horrible disease the invisible
enemy we call it
occur in people over 24 years of age
think of that 99.8
occur in people over 24 years of age for
this reason
it could be safer for them to live at a
school rather than
live with their older parents or
grandparents
i got to go to school we've got to open
up we've got to open up our schools and
open up our businesses
and a lot of it has been open but we can
do better
as we move forward the number of cases
is not by any means the most important
metric to focus on because the fact is
we have more cases because we have far
more testing than any country in the
world there's no country that's even
close
we've done more testing and better
testing than any country and many of
these countries that
the media was putting up as a shining
example of
success that right now in massive
outbreaks you see what's going on in
many of the countries that you
constantly mentioned far more
important is who the virus is infecting
that's why our strategy and attention
are focused on preventing the cases that
are
most likely to require hospitalization
or result in death those that afflict
the elderly and those with certain
underlying health conditions all the
while acting to prevent
hospital overcrowding if you look at
some of the states that had a flare-up
recently they're all doing very well
florida is going down
rapidly i want to give a lot of credit
to the governors
florida's going down and arizona
is going down way down they've done a
fantastic job
california as you know is going down
and many other locations it's doing very
well and many locations are
really in fantastic shape
some with very little of any problem
large portions of the united states
those advocating for a never-ending
blanket nationwide lockdown
have no answer for what it would do to
the mental physical and social health of
millions of american children
and people this includes parents where
they have to stay home with their
children because and they lose their
work and they lose their job because
their children isn't at school they have
to have somebody to take care of it and
they want to take care of their child
they don't trust people the society must
put the health and safety of our
children first a man who has
the respect of everybody he's highly
respected by me and
anybody on this subject
he's the expert dr scott atlas is here
from stanford
and he's been working with us for a
period of time and i thought it would be
great he was
saying things to me the other day i said
it would be great if you could tell that
to the media
so this is the first time i've shared
the platform
and uh it's an honor to do so scott is
truly uh
he's a brilliant man he's a wonderful
man and he cares about this subject very
much and
i'd like to ask scott to come up please
and say a few words thank you scott
thank you thank you mr president
uh obviously a great honor to be here
and a great honor to serve
this president who's really focused on
the very important parts of the pandemic
and uh
i'm new here i'm just sort of getting
involved but i want to thank you and the
vice president
and the entire team the task force team
and all the people who are not very
visible really
for working so hard uh these people are
working 24
7. and uh it's it's quite amazing
and i think the we today we had a
fantastic event that i'll just
mention on opening the schools because
the president's priority is to open the
schools and open them
safely and have parents
have the options to either use open
schools or do whatever they can to
eventually get back to open schools
including any
kind of hybrid or other arrangement they
may want to do it was a great event
we had a group of fantastic parents
teachers medical experts
and it went very well and so i i won't
spend a lot of time up here but uh thank
you very much and i hope i can help out
in some way
thank you see you thank you
you mentioned the executive orders that
you signed are we now
unlikely to see any more stimulus
legislation before the election
we're giving 400 and we are
in constant touch with governors also
who they'll be making
perhaps a contribution they have options
they can do it or they don't have to do
it i think most of them will do it
we're also doing a payroll tax cut which
is a massive number that's a very big
number
and that's a number that's bigger than
any of the numbers we talked about
and the beauty of that is it really
incentivizes
companies and because it's both a
company cut and a
a employee cut so that much
really very much incentivizes people
to uh go back to work and work hard and
the company to hire people back
and we've had some of the great economic
minds saying that's the most important
cut that would be the best cut you could
do we couldn't get the democrats to even
think about
agreeing to it it's not the democrat way
i guess
because it just seems that whether it's
larry kudlow or
any of your many friends that's the one
they wanted the most would you say larry
and so we're doing that and that was
never even really discussed because that
was
taken off the table by the democrats
immediately and this is every week every
week you get a check or a month or
bi-weekly this is a major
amount of money that you're getting
directly so
it's really uh you know it's a very big
number it's a very substantial number
and this is
don't forget this is an addition to the
to the 400
and uh this is a a
big number and now at the end of the
year
the assumption that i win i'm going to
terminate the payroll tax
which is another thing that some of the
great economists would like to see
done will be paying into social security
through the general fund
and it works out very nicely
if biden would win he wouldn't do that
because he's going to double and triple
everybody's taxes
he's going to have to explain that one
and as you know he's also going to
quadruple regulations he wants to put
regulations on
one of the reasons that we had the kind
of numbers and
and big bounces that you've seen i mean
we closed it up we saved millions of
lives and now we open it and we bounce
right back where we were
it looks like we'll be bouncing right
back where we were but one of the
reasons is because we cut
so many uh horrible regulations
and biden with his new partner
kamala will uh if you think he's going
to put it all back
but many times more i mean they want to
increase regulations and that's just
going to drive
companies out and it's going to drive
people out it's going to drive them to
other countries and it's going to make
us
not competitive with other countries
please
thank you mr president i'd like to
highlight a kind of odd situation in the
last
hour or so if you googled antifa.com
it would take you straight to joe
biden's website his official campaign
website
odd situation we don't know who's behind
that but it raises an interesting
leadership question
should joe biden the democrat party
kamala harris should they
publicly denounce uh the antifa as
a as a domestic terrorist organization
they should i think they're afraid to
it's
uh in my book it's virtually a part of
their campaign
antifa the democrats act like gee i
don't know exactly what that is take a
look at
portland take a look at any place you
want to take a look at
they're all over the place they were
here we put on a 10-year
prison sentence if you knocked down any
statues two months ago and since then we
haven't seen much of them
we had to send uh border security
we sent actually homeland and border and
different forms of homeland to uh
to portland in order to you you know
what we had to do we had to save
they wanted to knock down a courthouse a
500 million dollar courthouse they
wanted to burn it down knock it down
and they were easily able to defend but
the mayor and the governor of the state
they didn't want to do that
and we actually sent our our people
there and they did a great job and they
were they did it easily but
in the meantime they went to other parts
of the city and they're doing damage and
we're recommending to the governor that
they call in national
security calling the national guard
we're willing to get
we would we would stop that problem in
one hour
we sent just defensive measures to
protect and save that
courthouse from being burned down or
knocked down
we also saved a couple of other
buildings federal buildings
uh because they were unable to do the
job i have to say this they have
really good police they have a great
group of people
that if they would be allowed to do
their job same with chicago and same
with new york and a couple of other
cities
if they allowed in chicago 25 000 police
and they're really good but they're not
allowed to do their job
in new york you have new york's finest
but they've totally taken away
their incentive they've they've taken
away their lives in a sense
because they don't allow them to do
their job they could do that job so
easily you wouldn't have a problem in
new york
and that includes with terrorism and
everything else they disbanded
they've cut by one billion dollars
their budget in new york one billion
dollars then crime is up by
200 250 percent depends on what week
you're looking at it's crazy what's
going on in new york
we could solve that problem easily but
we don't have to because they should be
able to do it themselves but they have
to give
the they have to give the honor back
it's it's an honor
they have to give the honor back to
their law enforcement groups
new york is great so is chicago
and in portland they could do the job if
they don't want to do that
we would send in gladly if they want the
national guard we'll take care of it in
one hour
it'll go very quickly as we did by the
way
if you take a look in minneapolis when
they were burning down minneapolis a
wonderful place but nobody's ever seen
anything like it after days
the very liberal and these are all run
by liberal democrats
every place i talk about is run because
we have great cities
and they're run by republicans
okay it's you know it's there's no magic
to it it's
obvious what's going on and these
the cities that i mentioned are all run
by liberal very liberal
democrats and it's very sad when you see
what's happening to new york it's very
sad when you see what's
happening to other cities not just those
three
other cities when you look at what's
happening it's not even
it's not even believable i left new york
almost four years ago
and you could see signs of problems
because de blasio was there he's a
horrific mayor just horrific
i mean people don't want to go there
anymore
he's not only is it bad with crime the
way he talks about the city and what he
does he's
horrific and when i see that it's a very
sad thing i left
uh almost four years ago right and
when i look and see what's happening to
a city that i love
that still has great potential
but it's going to have to be brought
back
because what happened in new york is is
it's not even believable what's
happening in chicago where
one weekend you have 78 people shot and
18
die in a weekend
and then successive weekends you have so
much of that happening and
it's it's not even it's really not even
believable
and if you let democrats run this
country and we've stopped it from going
other places have you let democrats run
this country you'll have
all of your cities be just like this
right thank you mr president
the heads of the boston and dallas that
today said that the
economy hasn't recovered strong enough
because the country hasn't contained the
virus
so what's your response to them and what
did that argue for a stronger federal
response
well you just saw other countries were
doing much better than
all other major countries peer countries
uh this chart came out just a little
while ago i thought i'd say
it's that kind of a question the wise
guy question
uh because i just went over the whole
thing we're doing better than
almost everyone with the economy and i
think we're
we're you know we face a headwind
because
uh democrats perhaps for political
reasons don't want to open up their
states
and that's having a huge toll that's
taken a huge toll
on people within those states when you
look at
north carolina you have a man doesn't
want to open it up you have you look at
michigan you look at some states
i mean they just want to keep these
people in there in their houses
in their prisons they call them prisons
and i think a lot of it's for political
reasons because they want to
look as bad as possible on november 3rd
but i don't think it's going to matter
because we're doing
so well in so many ways as far as the uh
the plague is concerned when you look at
the numbers take a look at what's going
on now with
other countries they're having flare-ups
that are very very substantial
and we've done very well we're helping a
lot of those countries
and those were model countries that you
used to talk about and say
how well they were doing except they
just exploded they just had
very big flare-ups you understand that
no we're doing very well
and i don't have to show you the charts
again but those charts are
at a level that nobody even thought
possible i think we're going to have a
fantastic third quarter
i think next year will be one of the
strongest years we've had
and this is with california being closed
down this is where
north carolina and and michigan and
tremendous states great states
uh are being closed by
uh for reasons i think that would that
scott would tell you you disagree
with right you disagree with he we spent
a great amount of time talking about it
we got to open up our country we
understand the disease we understand who
it hits we have to protect our elderly
people especially
our elderly people that are not well we
have to protect them
but we understand it and we understand
it well we've learned a lot
and we're going to have the vaccine soon
and we're going to have the therapeutics
soon
going to come out very soon and we're
very proud of the people
the job they've done yeah please thanks
mr president um
joe biden and kamala harris just
appeared together in their first
campaign event right before you got up
on this podium can you tell us if you
watched their remarks and give us your
reaction to them
i didn't watch i saw just a moment of
him speaking a moment of her speaking
and it was enough look he made a choice
he picked her
i watched her i watched your poll
numbers go
boom boom boom down to almost nothing
and she left angry she left mad
there was nobody more insulting to biden
than she was she said horrible things
about him
including accusations made about him by
a woman where she i guess believed the
woman
and now all of a sudden she's uh running
to be
vice president saying how wonderful he
is
i thought it was a very unusual pic
because she said such bad things and you
know better than anybody would
you know you won't write it because you
know you don't want to do that but
you know better than anybody uh she said
horrible things about him
horrible things and she mocked him
openly mocked him that's why i thought
that was a very risky pick
because i'm sure that'll be played back
not necessarily by me but others it'll
be played back
the other thing if you look she wants a
3 trillion
tax hike no fracking
how do you think no fracking in
pennsylvania is going to play
that's a big fracking state if you
didn't have
energy produced that way you would have
taxes that would triple and you'd have
unemployment that you wouldn't believe
in pennsylvania last you had the best
year they've ever had
texas last year the best year they've
ever had oklahoma best year
almost every state in our nation last
year had the best year they've ever had
and they're going to have that again
next year and you can see that by what
but think of it
she wants no fossil fuels no fossil
fuels
really tell that to texas and then i
hear
trump is only one point up in texas no
they said the same thing with
crooked hillary clinton they said texas
is in play
trump is down in texas and then i won
texas immediately when they said the
polls are closed
trump has won texas i won by a lot
and i won georgia by a lot it's the same
thing over it's almost like a
duplication of what happened before
except we have much more energy now than
we ever did in 2016 and we had a lot
we had record amounts in 2016. but you
you take a look at the tax cuts we
gave the biggest tax cut in the history
of our country
and the biggest regulation cuts in the
history of our country by far
right he wants to increase everybody's
taxes
and she's one of the people that
wants that i mean you take a look at
that she wants to
defund or at least substantially reduce
money going to police departments
and you can't do that you can't do that
it's actually got to be the opposite
i've been endorsed by
so many police departments i'm getting a
really good one this week
that you'll be seeing really big really
good
but who could ever what what police
department what law enforcement group
could ever support
joe biden where
he said things that are so bad and so
foolish
frankly so stupid in terms of in terms
of crime and what would happen
so we're getting all of law enforcement
uh we're getting the military she wants
to
spend much less in our military i've
rebuilt the military we have the
strongest military now
much of the equipment is coming in all
made in the united states 2.5 trillion
dollars we spent
when i took over we had a military that
was totally
uh it was in terrible terrible shape
it was depleted it was a depleted
military
old planes old tanks old everything
and we have a beautiful brand new
military with the best people in the
world we've never had anything like it
some of the equipment is still coming in
no we have we've done a real job
and i think we're going to be extremely
successful i was surprised that he
picked her very surprised because of the
horrible way she talked about him and
frankly because
she dropped like a rock i didn't when i
ran i ran against
17 people mostly governors and senators
some others ben
carson was very strong very good a
couple of others but mostly governors
mostly
senators and i ran
and i went up she ran and she went down
to
rock bottom i don't think she ever got
to run her first
to take a vote in her first in the first
state
uh and uh so generally speaking you
don't want to pick somebody that
went down she went down but she went
down in a very
terrible way and she said horrible
things about biden
she said far worse about biden than i
ever did
and now she's running as vice president
so how does that work please
mr president thanks for taking my
question uh i'm wondering tonight if you
might have any
words of encouragement for middle
schoolers or high schoolers starting the
school year strictly
online you might be frustrated wondering
how they're going to get through the
next quarter
missing their friends and teachers this
morning you might have any words of
encouragement for them
it's such a fair question such a good
question yeah i mean you hear what
i was saying or scott will be involved
and he'll be talking to you over the
next couple of days what he's
saying from great experience no i feel
very badly for him
and i have a feeling that on november
4th somebody's going to announce schools
are open
the country's open everything's open i
really believe a lot of it's done for
political reasons
you want to know the truth i think so
but you're right
online is not the same as being in the
classroom and that's been proven it's
been proven
loud and clear yeah any other questions
mr president
mr president um you've warned several
times that if joe biden is elected
president
that there will be an invasion uh in
suburban neighborhoods it's a sentiment
that you expected to tweet again this
morning
what exactly do you mean by invasion
uh what i mean is people are going to
become
they're going to be opening up areas of
your neighborhood which they're doing
and now they're going to do they wanted
to expand it and they will expand it
if for any reason they're going to in my
opinion destroy suburbia
and just so you understand 30 plus
of the people living in suburbia are
minorities
african-american asian-american
hispanic-american
they're minorities 30 the number's even
higher it's
they say 35 but i like to cut it a
little bit lower you know why that way i
can never get myself in too much trouble
with the
fake news but 30 plus
are minorities living in suburbia
and when they go in and they want to
change zoning so that
you have lots of problems where they
want to build low income housing
you want something where people can
aspire to be there not something where
it gets hurt
badly and that's what happens so
with suburban women suburban men
i think they feel very strongly about
what i'm doing
it's a very i mean it's a very fair
question it's a very important question
but they fought all their lives to be
there and then all of a sudden
they have something happen that changes
their life and changes
what they fought for for so many years
john please
uh two quickly thank you mr president uh
i know you were briefed on it have you
decided
where are you going to give your
acceptance speech at so we're looking at
gettysburg
a magnificent site i've been there a
number of times just a magnificent site
and we're looking at the white house
and i would say it's really down to
those two
the white house would be uh much easier
from the standpoint of secret service
and
you know the movement of hundreds of
people as you know
i would say we love them both i love
gettysburg but it's
this is simpler would be magnificent the
white house is a
the white house is the white house
gettysburg is one of the great
and historic sites of our country
frankly as far as i'm concerned of the
world so
one of those two i'll probably be
announcing it over the next week or so
maybe a question about payroll taxes if
if you permanently rescind the payroll
tax
how do you pay for social security we're
taking it out of the general fund
and what we'll do what we'll be doing is
if we do that we'll get it approved in
that case by congress
and we'll take the money from other
places other than we will not take it
from social security
in any way shape or form how do you fund
from the general fund when the general
fund
just incurred a debt of 2.8 trillion
dollars right we're gonna have
tremendous growth
we have tremendous growth you take a
look at what's happening here
next year unless somebody comes in who
doesn't know what they're doing and they
start raising taxes and forcing
everybody to leave the country or
leave their jobs and companies to close
we will have tremendous growth you will
see growth like you haven't seen in a
long time
since you didn't see carla harris's
remarks today i wonder if we could just
get you to respond to
one thing that she said sure um
she said that your refusal to get
testing up and running
you are paraphrasing you're
flip-flopping on social distancing
and masks and your delusional
belief that you know better than the
experts
all of that in in her words a reason
that one american dies proven 19 every
minute
what do you think of that uh i think
that's probably one of the reasons she
was a terrible candidate and was forced
to leave the race because
she got her facts wrong you know she's
very bad on facts she's very weak on
facts and just so you understand
we've done more testing than any country
in the world by far
that includes india which has 1.5
billion people that includes
china that includes every country in the
world we've done more testing
we have better testing than any country
in the world they call they want to know
where do we get it how do we get it
we have better testing than any country
in the world when you do as much testing
as us however
as you understand you develop more cases
if you test it on set of
65 million people which is what we've
done
when you test that many people you're
going to find cases that normally you
wouldn't see if you go to mexico and you
go to other countries you'll see they do
almost no testing
they test if somebody's not feeling well
they test if somebody is
symptomatic they test very little they
test very little
we've done more testing than anybody in
the world we've done the best job of any
country in the world and that includes
from
making ventilators that nobody else
could have done we are the
ventilator king of the world we're
supplying the whole world now
in a few short months with ventilators
that are very hard to
produce very expensive very complex very
delicate
very very important we've done a great
job and then on top of that when you
look at the numbers how we were impacted
less than these other countries
and now you look at the explosion of
countries that you would have
said did such a good job and some of
them had advantages
over us for obvious reasons having to do
with the
pandemic but when you look at the job
that we've done compared to others
we've done a great job and she i read
today that she's very short on facts
uh she i think she's going to be a big
failure and i think i look forward to
the debate between her and mike pence
because i think he'll do even better
against her
than he did against senator kane which
was a total wipeout
so we'll see how it all works out uh all
right one more
yeah please thank you thank you very
much
thank you um just ask what do you say to
those critics who
argue you're trying to sow distrust in
democracy and deliberately try to
sabotage the post office to
undermining men in voting which a lot of
people need i see the democrats are
sabotaging the post office because
they're not approving 25 billion dollars
that was requested
so they're sabotaging the post office
and they're not allowing
the post office to function properly and
they're certainly not allowing universal
mail-in votes when they do that but
equally importantly they're not allowing
3.5 billion dollars in funds to do
voting that they'd like to do therefore
all of this
and all of the tremendous mistakes that
were made with regard to mail-in voting
all of these tremendous mistakes
you can't even you can't even do it i
would imagine the courts you know this
is in many courts right now
they're showing all of the disasters
that have taken place just in the last
short period of time in the last two
months with respect to universal
mail-in voting it's just like a total
catastrophe what's happening
and we can't let that happen go ahead
real fast
one is is about you had uh
graphs about the economics of the
probate
but deaths in america are still going up
whereas in europe
right now zero deaths in uk zero deaths
in france
what's going on cases if you look at
cases and the cases are going up because
we do so much testing and we find it
and i call it fake media gold because we
do so much more testing than any other
country and when you do all that testing
you find cases go ahead steve real quick
you've got these trade talks from china
going on is it possible you would pull
out of the trade deal with china if
they're not
meeting their commitment we've taken a
lot of money from china in the last year
and a half
that no other president has taken in
we've done things to china that nobody
else has done to china or even thought
of doing it
with 25 tariffs and taken in billions
and billions of dollars tens of billions
of dollars
and given then given the farmers as an
example 12 billion one year
16 billion another year and made the
farmers extremely happy you don't hear
them complaining they were targeted by
china
but i'm very angry at china
because they let this horrible disease
they let this horrible plague
come into our country and come into the
world and they should have been able to
stop it
they stopped it from going into china
they should have been able to stop it
so i'm very angry at china thank you
very
it's much for the federal government so
why are you saying it's 400
mr president
yes
my
you